OK.
Another question that came in, David.
Joe Biden is expected to select his vice president
around August 1st.
Who do you think would hurt Biden the most?
So earlier know when was it?
Last week.
I said that I believe Elizabeth Warren should
be Joe Biden's vice presidential pick.
This is a different question, not who would
be best, but who would be worst.
So the first thing is to understand what is
the goal of selecting a vice president?
There's essentially two goals.
One, don't cause a problem for the presidential
candidate.
So Sarah Palin did did not help John McCain
back in 2008.
Now, McCain was already losing, but Palin
was a cartoonish sideshow and certainly did
not help.
And number two, can you increase the electorate?
Can you bring in some additional people to
bolster support for the presidential candidate?
So you look at someone like Paul Ryan.
Paul Ryan didn't do much one way or the other
for Romney in terms of creating scandals are
saying crazy things.
Arguably, Paul Ryan maybe helped Romney a
little bit when it comes to the electorate
being from where it was.
Ryan from Virginia.
I think Romney being, you know, a massive
former Massachusetts governor, maybe not didn't
really do much one way or the other.
Mike Pence didn't do much for Trump in terms
of bad news headlines.
He just stayed out of the way.
But maybe Pence helped in the Midwest.
Maybe Pence helped with the evangelical vote,
which ultimately mostly went to Donald Trump
anyway.
I believe if Joe Biden were to choose Hillary
Clinton, it would probably be bad.
That would probably hurt him.
If Joe Biden were to choose, you know, an
actual Republican, if Joe Biden announces,
I don't know, Ted Cruz is my running mate,
I think it's a real problem for Biden.
I think that.
But obviously, he's not going to do that.
And if Joe Biden picks someone with a lot
of baggage that can be attacked, that would
be a problem.
So, for example, Amy Klobuchar, it was revealed
in the aftermath of the killing of George
Floyd that she had been involved in decisions
not to go after Derek Schavan, who ultimately
is the officer that killed George Floyd with
the need of the neck.
Once that went public, it was obvious that
Clowe, Bashar was damaged in terms of a vice
presidential candidate.
She came out and said, I'm dropping out because
it should be a woman of color.
But it was clear at that point she wasn't
going to be selected anyway.
That type of baggage could be damaging to
Joe Biden.
Obviously, it's not going to be close, Bashar.
Now, I've got a couple e-mails from people
who said the Native American thing would be
baggage for Elizabeth Warren.
I don't know that it would.
I really don't know that it would.
I think, listen, if you want to talk about
baggage.
Kamala Harris, his record is California attorney
general prosecuting the war on drugs and putting
a lot of black folks in jail, in prison, in
prison.
I think that that may be baggage that Biden
does not need, but I may be wrong there.
So, again, the point here is when you pick
a V.P., you want someone who's not going to
get a ton of attention because typically it
will be negative attention.
Number two, you want someone who maybe can
help you in terms of expanding your base of
support.
And number three, you want someone who's not
going to bring some kind of baggage that is
going to disproportionately become subject
matter for discussion if you disagree with
me.
Let me know.
We've got a great bonus show for you today
to become a member and get the bonus show.
You need only go to join Pacman dot com and
sign up to exciting things going on next week.
Tuesday night at 8:00 p.m. Eastern, the third
David Pakman show chess tournament.
It will be at David Pakman dot com slash chess.
You can go there now and register for free
for the tournament.
This is all free.
I'm not selling anything.
Big shocker to a lot of people, nothing is
being sold here.
Just a community building opportunity.
David Pakman dot.com slash chest's register
for free tournament, 8:00 p.m. on Tuesday
the 14th.
Number two, also on Tuesday the 14th, we will
be doing a single day membership special.
The reason we're doing it is a sad reason
you might think July 14th.
What's that?
What's the deal?
Back in twenty nineteen in early July.
We did a Fourth of July special.
Hundreds of people signed up.
All those memberships came due for renewal
a few days ago.
And because of the virus, hundreds of those
people who signed up in 2019 couldn't afford
to renew.
I got a lot of e-mail saying, I'm sorry, David,
I want to support you, but I can't.
So we lost hundreds of members in the first
four days of July.
Not good.
So we're trying to counteract that and sort
of re up.
On Tuesday, we'll do a mailing with a single
day membership special.
It'll be a beautiful discount.
You want to be notified about it?
Just get on my mailing list at David Pakman
dot com.
We will see you on today's Bonas show.
And then next week.